okay I was in London over the sort of
Christmas to New Year's week and I
participated in what may be one of the
most pompous and elitist activities ever
or maybe not we'll see what people think
I'm not gonna start with that I will
remind you I am on instagram at david
pakman a lot of our viewers following my
travels there during the vacation week
i'll talk more about the trip itself on
the bonus show today but a couple of
pictures that people really seem to like
on instagram the first one here this is
a picture that I took and I'll explain
to you what's going on here at the
British Museum fantastic Museum museums
in London are mostly free extraordinary
museums there this is me standing in
front of the rosetta stone and of course
the rosetta stone is an old stone that
contains writing in three languages I
believe it's old Greek hieroglyphics and
one other language I forget what it is
and this was a key artifact in starting
to sort of translate and decipher some
of these ancient languages and the
reason you can't see much of the the
rosetta stone in the picture let's keep
the picture up for a bit longer pad the
reason you can barely see the rosetta
stone is because this is a massive
people that is pushing and shoving in
order to take a picture of the rosetta
stone on their mobile phone through
incredibly thick glass as you can see
there we've got pretty thick glass there
very reflective because of the high key
lighting this is almost the same thing I
experienced at the Louvre in Paris with
the Mona Lisa people pushing and shoving
to take pictures of something that if
you really want to look at the details
of you would go to Google Images I don't
get why people do this and there were
some other tourists there sort of in the
second layer you can see I'm kind of
back from the main crowd in the picture
who were looking we were looking at each
other saying what are you doing what
what what is this I mean I can kind of
understand it if you want to get a
picture of yourself and your family and
friends in front of whatever I take a
picture of right but if you're just
going to focus on that itself I mean
there's there's hundreds of thousands of
different pictures out there that are
better than the one you're gonna take if
you're looking to take a look at the
writing on the rosetta stone you're not
going to see anything in these
highly reflective low qualities
cellphone camera pictures I really don't
get it just enjoy being there enjoy the
the atmosphere take a look at the
Rosetta Stone read the little plaques
that they have describing what's going
on I will never understand this behavior
and it's just one of the one of the many
places I've been where you start to see
this now let's get to an activity I
participated in at my girlfriend's
request I will say called afternoon tea
in London known to some as high tea call
it what you want when Louis former
producer Louis used to say he doesn't
drink beers like Budweiser and Coors he
drinks microbrews people said that's
elitist Lewis is being elitist if Lewis
was criticized for that I am ready for
an s storm Pat as a result of me
participating in afternoon tea in London
and as you can see in the picture I've
got the teapot there you've got the
little sandwiches that they bring you
are gone they were on the plate in front
of me that was the first thing I ate I'm
more of a savory guy and then you see
the various scones and endless sweets
and pastries on on the table I am not
that big of a sweet and pastry guy so I
could have a couple bites of these
things but I'm more into the savory it's
just a sugar overload you know yeah I
get that that's why they're still on the
table and I think your arm outstretched
on the the armrest there of the chair I
think that adds to the elitists them a
little bit more my pose also I mean it's
almost like just when you go to
afternoon tea all of a sudden I think
the chairs are designed if you can put
it up one more time I think the chairs
are designed so you can't really just
sit up your by it almost puts you into a
very arrogant sitting position I think
if you just relax
maybe always relax yeah so I'll talk
more about the the trip on the bonus
show today that I can tell you the main
thing in England is not the food at
least not the English food best Indian
food I've ever had in my life I had in
London but British pub food is very
similar to Irish pub food of which there
are 10,000 in Boston yeah the Brits are
not known for their cuisine I would say
I think
their fish and chips then that's about
all I did have fish and chips twice and
the street fish and chips I had were way
better than the ones I had in an actual
restaurant now even though you're vegan
like if you went you do is the if you're
When in Rome
you would have fish and chips in London
I'm sure no you're very wrong on that
okay I have had fish and chips in London
it was just before I was be free
veganism yeah okay yeah what we're gonna
dig into that a little more on the on
the bonus show today okay so remember
follow all of the hijinks that I end up
bumping into on Instagram at David
Pakman